une touche de féminité dans cet atelier
de métallurgie dans une entreprise
traditionnelle mais à la pointe de la
technologie
christine mafli fabriqués par laser
évolution ces objets de décoration
aujourd'hui premier essai pour une
nouvelle création une poupée russe
infographiste de formation elle a eu
l'idée d'utiliser le savoir faire
industriel de notre région
christine maaf lui a créé son entreprise
vénère à création il y a deux ans voilà
c'est bon il ya l optimum qui m'embête
son atelier boutique se trouve à
valentigney mais c'est surtout grâce à
son site internet qu'elle se fait
connaître et qu'elle vend dans une
petite région comme la nôtre c'est très
difficile d'être revues et sites
internet c'est un endroit a lieu une
boutique qui est vu par beaucoup de
monde et ça supprime les intermédiaires
entre vous et clients donc la marche
c'est pour vous donc la marche est pour
moi et c'est pour ça qu'en fait la marge
et les pales grande pour que le produit
il reste accessible
sinon ainsi ces produits là aujourd'hui
on les commercialise dans les boutiques
ça sera beaucoup plus cher pour
l'acquéreur
direction la haute saône saulnot 50
habitants au milieu de la forêt c'est un
lieu idéal pour hugo de la vesle
ébéniste qui utilisent les bois locaux
il s'est lancé seul il y a neuf ans
aujourd'hui six personnes travaillent
avec lui et ses réalisations parts dans
le monde entier le développement de
l'entreprise est dû en partie à son site
internet
notre seule vitrine en fait c'est le
site de vente en ligne qui nous permet
de faire des ventes sur toute la france
et même en europe
on est en train de traduire le site
internet en allemand et en anglais pour
nous développer encore un petit peu à
l'export donc l'intérêt c'est pas
d'économiser les surfaces de vente dans
les grandes villes qui sont très très
cher et qu'il faudrait multiplier
il n'y a plus de loyer et de charges
mensuelles très très lourde d assise sûr
qu'on voit les trois où je me trouvais
sur des oeufs
il concentre son investissement sur le
site avec le référencement le
rédactionnel et surtout les photos pour
convaincre le client mobilité de choisir
la hauteur d'assise il va falloir qu'ils
fassent confiance aux produits et ça
passe par le descriptif donc la qualité
rédactionnelle du site
le graphisme l'ergonomie globale du site
et bien entendu la qualité des photos
les visuels sont qu'on n'a aucune chance
de générer des ventes
un site internet supprimer intermédiaire
permet aux designers de garder sa plus
value il met aussi à portée de clic le
monde entier internet + créativité plus
travail bien fait et si c'était la
recette du succès